brian is with us in Dallas Texas hey
Brian welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks to ever having me up here well
better than I deserve how can I help
so I'm 29 years old I'm married and have
just had my second child right now my
wife is a stay-at-home she's will be
going back to work
about a month which a lot another $2,500
towards our monthly income I had been
working on my emergency phone party
knowing you I looked at my phone she
phones and was able to do it three to
five months my bills days I heard about
15,000 on that account
right now I have corn oats so I've got
my truck payoffs about 18 or seizing
about 13 her car we recently got again
prior to noon
but now going into debt and it's about
28,000 what's your household income
right now it's 82 whenever she goes back
to work it should be about 130 okay and
these two cars are worth what now one of
they were my brand new comer and we have
we have $28,000 on that
my trucks and I was 2016 and I about
13,000 on that yeah your car though or
this last car purchase is over in the
stupid zone for sure the here's the
thing you can't get rich when you own a
whole bunch of stuff and when everything
you own going down in value
sure and the only thing you owns going
down in value you got $40,000 worth of
depreciating assets and that's the only
thing you own so you know these cars are
bad shape you got to get this cleaned up
man like it take that 15,000 go towards
my truck and pay that off completely
yeah that's what I would do that today
and then I would get on a super tight
budget the two of you look at this and
say if we're going to keep this new
stupid car we bought we have to pay it
off immediately we have to pay it off
very very very fast well I
mmm and we see you're making a hundred
you got to do it in less than a year
fortunately her and we were able to pay
all of my bills using money income and
we that was by design so all of her
income can go straight to the car
fortunately I finally decided to bring
her involved in finances and she's on
board with the envelope theory with non
essentials and she's been well I don't
all of your income going to anything I
want you guys to put all of your
household income in a pile and live on
as little as you can possibly live on
and pay that car off fast so I think
you're gonna have to more aggressively
than what you're talking about and then
the last part that really throws a
wrench know that is again mistakes were
made we both have our name on a co-sign
loans or a vehicle for my family one of
which my my brother was late on twice
really dropping my credit score and he
only has three thousand left on that is
it beneficial for me to pay off that one
or assist on that and have him reimburse
me to prevent my credit score from
getting any lower I'm not worried about
your credit score you need to stop
borrowing money anyway
sure sure I do want him to get the
stupid thing paid off if he doesn't
you're going to reach over and pay it
off or it's gonna throw they're gonna
come after you so um you know they they
need to get lit up on that there's only
one of these or there's two of these
there unfortunately there are two of
these so who's the other one my wife has
her name on my other brothers loans and
it's worth a thousand good Lord okay
mistakes were made yeah I know they
weren't I mean you're usually left your
family vulnerable trying to help your
brothers who weren't brilliant wise we'd
made this decision wide as we got
married so we won't really we didn't
have many bills at the times that we
thought it was a good idea but after
listening to the podcast we realized how
well we actually are so Mac modem I'm
with you yeah let's pay off your truck
today and let's just monitor these other
two loans as hard as we can let's push
them to get them paid office
as possible and then when we get her car
paid off in a year the next thing you're
gonna do is build up your emergency fund
you've known that from listening to the
podcast and I'm gonna go ahead and put
enough extra in your emergency fund to
pay off the two brothers cars if they
don't get them paid off just be ready if
they ever go into default before they
get repo'd you reach over and pay them
off and then you force the sale of that
car you do not allow them to keep the
car if you pay it off so that makes
sense and because that's not a me if
they are if they're not going to pay the
bill the car needs to be sold and you
got to write the check for the
difference and you need to have the
extra emergency fund to be able to do
that but then you just monitor this and
you just ride herd on them and make sure
that that they get this thing on cleaned
up but yeah you have one year to pay off
your wife's car and you guys can do that
you're making over $100,000 a year I'm
talking about 28,000 out of a hundred
that's doable but together all your
income together we're on a budget and
together we're attacking that to get
that paid off and then you've got these
two cars paid for and then you build
your emergency fund up that should I
think that was your only debt I think
that's what you said so you're on your
way you're doing smart stuff now you've
turned the corner and you've recognized
what didn't work and you're not doing
anymore so that's that's all anybody can
do we've all made mistakes hey thanks
for the call
[Music]